foreign
if this was run like a business
and it went bankrupt it wouldn't get any
more money
right it would be done it's a it it's
failed your plan failed now it's time
for a new plan it doesn't work like that
in homeless advocacy they get more money
and more money and more money
[Music]
oh
I'm the CEO of vetcom dot us also the
executive director of house the heroes
and I have lived in San Diego this year
20 years the amount of money that our
city is willing to spend on hotels for
the homeless
all of it is just to take a ton of money
in and little of that money goes out to
the actual homeless people other than to
to temporarily house them if you're
going to do housing first because it's
kind of our Mantra here on the West
Coast it's you know that's what people
want to do that's what they vote for
there are people that can work for like
the housing first model can work for
people who were just housed right it can
work for people who are desperately
trying to get jobs it can work for a
certain bucket of uh the homeless but it
does not work well for people who are
mentally ill and are on drugs
it's a huge failure on our part to think
we're going to take them off the street
and somehow magically just because
they're in a hotel room that they're
going to be free of drugs and alcohol
and their mental illness they're just
trying to clean up a little bit of the
people and get them out of the Public's
Vision so they can get voted back in
they're not actually digging down to the
root of the problem if they fix the
Homeless Problem the money goes away the
money stops so what big cities like to
do they like to bring in a ton of funds
and not let a ton of funds go back out
because infrastructurally they're
they're employing a ton of people they
have all these programs that are
supposed to help when really at the end
of the day they don't actually
effectively change anything
foreign